let's speak to the shadow brexit
secretary secure starmon
joins us now from Westminster secure
many thanks for being with us very good
morning to you I hope you don't mind but
of course at the breaking news this
morning relating to two matthew hedges
and your response as presumably you
believe some pretty decent work some
adroit work by the air foreign secretary
yeah I heard what you read of what the
foreign secretary said and on this
occasion I agree with him
on all fronts this is really good news
and a great relief for Matthew and for
his family but I agree with what the
foreign secretary said about this well
let's turn shall we - of course the
issue of the day the hard graft that
tourism is is going to have to indulge
in if she is to get that deal through
the House of Commons I mean simply put
it's not gonna happen is it
it looks very very unlikely she's got
between eighty to a hundred of our own
MP saying they're not going to vote for
it she's got the dup against all of the
opposition parties are gonna vote
against an even where there was
discussion in recent weeks about some
Labour MPs might vote with her that's
simply not going to happen listen Andy
and he made it clear yesterday that
she's not gonna vote with the Prime
Minister so at the moment it's just
impossible to see how she gets it
through I think that question therefore
for the prime ministry in Prime Minister
is what's your plan be you're sort of
charging on regardless of the obvious
consequences to sort of crash this what
is your plan B well the suggestion this
morning is that she would be very happy
to debate on TV Jeremy Corbyn on the
issue of brexit I suspect you'd welcome
that wouldn't you yeah I think Jeremy
already has welcomed it if the Prime
Minister is going to issue that
invitation then bring it on she declined
of course in the general election last
year to have such a debate so I'm glad
if she's now up for it I have to say it
does sort of look as if she's tilting
towards general election territory if
that's where she's going here's the
thing I've been asking I Stephen Barclay
exactly the same question this morning
he was unable to provide a direct answer
what happens what happens if the high
of Commons says no they vote against
this deal what comes next
you appear to be suggesting that Teresa
may might have an eye on the horizon and
a general election well we passed
legislation that said that if the deal
goes down as it looks like it will then
the Prime Minister has to make a
statement saying what she's going to do
next now in the legislation it says
she's got 21 days to do that
I don't for a minute think that she's
going to take that long I think she'll
come back within hours to say what she
intends to do and I don't know what she
will say what I do know is this that the
majority of MPs in the House of Commons
are against leaving without a deal and
amber Rudd from her cabinet position
said that last week so the idea that we
either accept whatever trees mayor has
brought back or have no deal is not one
that the House of Commons is going to
take lightly and there be huge
resistance to that and the options
really are that she goes and has another
go at negotiation somehow there's all
there's a general election or we press
on two other options such as a public
vote obviously we're here well the prime
minister says but I think Parliament is
to assert control at that stage I mean
okay you mentioned renegotiations then
it's been appointed point made by
yourself and others on the labor front
bench there actually you could have done
a better job that you could in the time
remaining at sort I a better deal
remembering of course that we are
supposed to be leaving the European
Union in March of next year I just want
to play you a few bits of words from
some voices that will be familiar from
some of the key players on the EU site
I'm inviting those who have to ratify
this deal in the House of Commons to
take this in consideration this is the
best deal possible for Britain this is
the best impossible for Europe this is
the only what's on the table it's the
only deal that's on the table and this
is the deal no table I don't think
there's anything more I know so yeah
vodka and I believe the Lithuanian prime
minister whose name escapes me at this
moment all suggesting that this not
simply is not just that mark Rutter in
fact it just came to me strangely in my
ear yeah they're all saying it's not
just that this is the best you but there
is no prospect
of any renegotiation and the time
between no and mark yeah well firstly I
don't agree this is the best deal I
think a much better deal could have been
dot if the Prime Minister had started in
a different place and if she had got a
consensus position across jean-claude
Juncker was standing in front of the
press lying then well no I don't say is
lying I mean whether it's that well
that's a matter of judgment isn't it
whether it's better or best in my
judgment it's not the best deal in my
judgment it's not a good deal and I'm
not alone in that because it looks like
the vast majority of MPs agree with me
on this issue the question then is
whether it can in any way be reopened
I'm not surprised the EU on the day that
they're signing the agreement are saying
that it can't be renegotiated can't be
reopened but they know as we know that
the UK crashing out of the EU without a
deal at all is very bad for the UK and
very bad for the EU so we're going to
have to look at this again whether we
like it or not after the vote because if
the vote has gone down we will have to
look at other options for the future of
the United Kingdom let's explain the
sequence of events yeah between no and
as leaving the European Union that would
eat alone the Labour Party to
renegotiate this and be give us a better
deal how do we get to that point yeah
and keep peeling labour politicians talk
about it but I don't quite understand
well point A to point C yeah I think the
only realistically the only options are
if the deal goes down that Parliament
decides the Prime Minister ought to
renegotiate because obviously labour
can't do it on their own because we need
Tory votes to say these are the
objectives you ought to have gone for so
there is that opportunity to say no you
must have you prime minister must have
another go to get something which really
has the confidence of Parliament
theoretically if that doesn't happen you
could have another group trying to
negotiate but I think realistically
we're going to have to save the Prime
Minister now that may not happen there
may not be time I accept that so that's
why when we looked at this at our party
conference we said if not then it has to
be a general election because this is a
massive failure of negotiation if not a
general election then other options
including a public vote so we were
trying at our party conference to sort
of look at the options I accept their
difficult I accept that you can't
necessarily achieve them
in the way you'd want but they seem to
me the realistic options which is
somehow mandate the Prime Minister to
get a different deal that actually has
the confidence of Parliament or a
general election or press onto other
options such as a public vote has the
Shadow Cabinet are or indeed just you
have you had discussions about the
prospect of a Labour government pausing
the article 50 process doing what sorry
I didn't quite heavy about pausing
article 50 well I'm not going to discuss
what we discusses Shadow Cabinet I don't
ever do that but it is obvious that once
we get to December we've only got three
months left and we do have to prevent
crashing out without a deal over in
Brussels there is a discussion about
whether there could be an extension for
a number of months and and there is the
suggestion that possibly it could but at
the moment my position is this that if
there's any need for an extension it's
purely and simply because the Prime
Minister has run down the clock but just
be absolutely clear secure you are 100%
open to the prospect of extending
article 50 or pausing that process so
that an incoming Labour government would
have the time needed to sort another
deal well we're not at that stage yet
but if if there's a general election
after this vote which is predicted to be
in the middle of December then it seems
to me obvious that something has to be
done
to ensure that the March deadline
doesn't inevitably lead to us crashing
out without a deal but we will be in
very different territory at that stage
we'll have to talk to in Parliament
enough to talk to you about what we do
next